joining us now let's give a warm Georgia
welcome Georgia Senate count
Canada
hello
just for the record yes yes
I think you're left oh
for the record family y'all didn't clap
as loud for me I'm just saying but yes
yeah that's that's family family yes
let's do a quick let's do yeah let's do
a quick pop how many In This Crowd think
that Herschel won the debate Friday
night
oh
yes oh
well to be honest
to be honest I think uh Raphael one I
think I won as well so it is a good idea
yeah I don't think he'd admit it though
yes you know
we had a conversation as friends we've
known each other for a long time he's in
my radio Studio we had push-up contests
I lost every one of them and I can do a
lot of push-ups yes so
I told you before you ran I said this is
going to get ugly they're going to
attack you they're going to smear you
they're going to slander you and do you
remember what you said to me no you said
to me is Sean I have fought my whole
life and they can do whatever they want
but I'm going to go and be the I'm going
to go be a public servant for the people
of Georgia and you know it's so funny I
have to though yeah
and I and I said like this George is my
family and right now I see a guy
pretending to be a senator and I hope
everyone watched the debate because he
uh came to the debate I think unprepared
and I think he got exposed and uh now
people see the differences between he
and I that I can uh start being a
senator on day one where he's still
behind two years and because those two
years we have high inflation we have
this border wide open we have problems
that's happening and they continue to
try to separate but I'm here to tell him
that it's time for him to go you know
let's talk about the things
that you're talking about running on
are we taxed too much we're we're way
over taxed right now we have high taxes
and then for them to hire 87 000 RS
agents those agents are going to come
after everyone here anyone making less
than two hundred thousand dollars are
coming after you instead of having uh
border agents and you know he we didn't
even get into that in the debate he
voted against 18 000 border agents you
know that was it was in the bill he
voted voted against that and you know
there's a lot of things that he's
pretending that he did for Georgia he
didn't and uh that's why I wanted him to
be exposed and I think right now things
are starting to come up you know you
mentioned that at the camp you didn't
mention that he did a settlement a cash
settlement so those kids couldn't talk
so they couldn't talk about the abuse
that happened at that camp but this race
ain't about what he done in his personal
life like they can bring up my personal
life as much as they want it's about
what he's doing to the people of Georgia
and I said that is time for it to stop
right now well I might have a slight
disagreement because
they've been going after you and your
personal life like with a
unprecedented amount of attacks and
you've answered all of them but here we
have in a domestic dispute using a car
as a weapon I don't know about everybody
else here I'm shocked he didn't get
arrested that was 2020. that's not that
long ago well what's strange about it is
uh you know I've been very transparent
you know they can continue to try to
bring up whatever I've been very
transparent because I'm very open
because right now the people need to
know the truth the truth is I had
problems years ago but I've been very
transparent and I came forward right now
he's sealed this divorce paper he's
hiding behind any court papers not just
though the kids can't talk and I want to
say if you're going to be a senator and
be honest that's the reason I told them
do not bear false witness don't pretend
that you know the Bible and you say
little scriptures because uh I said
don't use the Bible as convenience and
then he made a statement also uh brought
Dr king's name in it which I thought was
totally wrong Dr King has nothing to do
with what he's doing at that church and
I thought that was totally insulting for
he to do that let me point out in the
crowd let's give a warm Georgia welcome
Dr alvita King is here supporting you
yeah yeah
and
and you know that's one of the things
that's one of the things I want people
to realize all you heard was excuses
from him right now he's been in office
for two years and we got these high
inflation it is that on his watch Tate
responsibility which he took no
responsibilities and then he got to the
point wouldn't even answer a question he
wouldn't even answer a question that
tells you right now who's prepared to be
a senator I said I'm not afraid to
answer a question to be a leader you got
to stand up and be the leader the
question
Ronald Reagan famously asked a question
are you better off than you were I'll
ask this crowd are you better off
now and they need to know this if you
vote for Raphael why not you're going to
get more and worse than what you're
getting right now you need to realize
that it gonna get worse than you're
getting right now that's the reason I
say it is time for him to go because
he's trying to separate us trying to
divide us at the same time they're gonna
it's gonna be government control it's
going to be government control even
mentioned in a debate person you're
trying to get the government to run our
lives yeah he was totally confused then
he got totally confused he didn't know
how to debate anymore so he got confused
on it and now he's out talking again but
that's all he's doing is talking not
doing any work for the people we have a
41 year high of inflation Joe Biden just
said over the weekend oh you know the
economy is doing great I'm like as usual
Joe doesn't know what day of the week it
is but
but in all seriousness right 41-year
high of inflation record high gas prices
70 percent of Americans live in paycheck
to paycheck and last week the AP came
out with a poll 46 percent of Americans
think that they are poor right now
because of yes all of the economic
wreckage that has been done in what 20
months between a month well think about
this and I say this he's voted with them
96 of the time but listen to this so he
either is a rubber stamp for Joe Biden
or he has no clue what he's doing think
about it they can only be one or two
either rubber stamp or Joe Biden or you
have no clue of what you're doing
because everyone have said Joe Biden is
headed in the wrong direction which
means he's headed in the wrong direction
as well so between the economy energy
borders Law and Order uh our school
crime crime okay
is there anything that he is advocating
for that you find yourself in any
agreement with or you go on 180 degrees
the other way well that's one thing he
said is this this this election going to
come down between he and I and he's
probably going to vote for me when he
goes to the poll because he realized
that uh it is that I'm the better man
for the job that's probably where it's
going to come down to so uh you know it
is hard for me right now with everything
that is happening to look and say that's
something that is doing well you know he
started trying to get accolades by
petting themselves on the back but I can
show you where it didn't help what he's
doing is hurting this country he's
hurting the people he's hurting
Georgians and when that inflation
reduction I I invited him to come down
to do a debate over he didn't want to do
it then so he finally did debate uh
Friday night and I'm happy he did it so
I thank you for doing it now everyone
see that you're a fraud you are that
wolf in sheath clothing that I've been
talking about
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else